o ato sexual do que quem fala o dark
sejam muito bem vindos é mais um vídeo e
ao estrado de jack um bigode
desconfigurando pública que abrange
letinho não consigo fazer agora eu sei
que por isso o indie rock bom nós
estamos aqui com farinas 7 fred em 24 a
lua e mission senhor quatro dias atrás
não saiu do seu traçado as coisas saem
só uma semana depois é qo barco vá
gastar a sola vargas llosa não tem um
bom pega as pipocas e vamos lá ok
estamos no nosso quarto nada de coisas
do aluno é meia noite vamos lá ver o que
o assaltaram e esquecem de aumentar o
volume o jet-set agora não consigo ver
bem as coisas aí alguém até agora ainda
nada pelo pps com qualquer coisa que ela
está não funciona porque o aluno já
pessoal em 'fúria 30 e 31 e hoje é de
quatro por isso a pessoa tirar um deus
sempre será que alguma coisa dentro do
armário não há nada ok são duas da manhã
é nada aconteceu até agora nada da lua
em nada das obras nada bulls erros nada
de bruxas o que aconteceu e se deus e aí
alguém fred
manning indica foxy nada eles não
pagaram a agenda da casa tiveram que ir
embora obviamente nem eu acho que foi
isso mesmo porque o alumínio é a de
qualquer coisa eu acho que era eu acho
que ele pelo ppb era quem era o fred né
ainda que coisa anda que coisa feia nos
pagaram havendo assim pelo menos um ano
aqui dentro que são quatro da manhã e
vamos lá estes já começa a ficar entre
11 e eu acho que tem alguém atrás da
câmera eye demônio já tinha trecho quase
que por dia agora acho que assim deverá
cana vamos deixar seguir à noite dois lá
e demora nisso eu sou exatamente iguais
aos originais 7 fredes normal né
nada do galo em espécie disse um
software microsoft obras ou
freqüentávamos cravou a frase aí 5 da
manhã haveres em jiegu ninguém mas não
se pode jogar antes da festa vai esta
manhã com os responsáveis da primeira
noite do rock estão me liga e eu já sei
o que vai acontecer é que o fox vai ser
baixo da cama nem ontem que o quanto
quem dá o inac sim o amor alguma
coisinha quer saber do texto a equipa
esquerda neoton âmbito da reforma da
obra também traz
obrigado pelo susto fox e e amanhã é um
novo dia
vamos pra noite do espero que estas
sejam que mais se fiava temos um nível
agudo boy é o boi não do strep nós
conseguimos apanhar o colunismo anel
boyle perdeu tem que esperar eu tenho
pra nós conseguimos apanhar temos duas
horas adiantadas mesmo ano lá ela o
homem anda versa a vencer até mim todo
boy
ae não faltam 18 segundos meu deus meu
deus eu vou perder eu vou perder o
tanque fará campanha por chicago vai
andar com fé e 432 um pai nem pro livro
é o bumbum é mais perto um ok vamos lá
pra noite 28 preparado para isso e nem
vamos lá ver o que é que mudou aqui a
tinta está mascarada né então fred
estavam no sector chutassem problema do
lixo e fred
vamos ter essa porta ok tá tranquilo por
enquanto não é nada
jackman os cios irados mesmo quando a
taxa era isso que eu queria dizer mas já
tem a investir em cima da cabeça e
tentar muito tempo as portas já vi time
deles mas não fica aqui falar em não
tomar atenção às coisas e agora vai
chamar a atenção da área não pode
esquecer que ela o embarque às bruxas
não assunto a a all já tinham eo boné
mascarada de ótica ou sei lá o quê que
isto é se vocês souberem o que cantar
aqui amaldiçoar esta casa de gão nos
comentários pessoal são todos no metrô
nem que seja apenas um eu não saí mas
cometem e é uma da manhã é eu não estou
nada assustado nada assustado cocaína
que ninguém mas demônios
eu acho que o foco senão vai parecer
nesta noite se é que há um foco é né ai
meu cuidado esata assim está apertado
acho que anda na cozinha nem ouviram uns
pratos da palavra luz buscar um pouco
aqui ainda está a caminhar com os pratos
boa dona de casa que o edson freire a
chatinha do estimado em cima da cama meu
deus eu tenho que tomar atenção à cama
ai eu tava legal saiu da cozinha o filho
da mãe está aqui eu sabia filho da mãe
ver que ela mais um molho que vamos
perder
calma calma a e o meu cunho luta na
esquerda o que é este está com o salário
ficará com muita pressão já há muita
pressão aqui uma coisa já estava tem
muito toque nem fechar a porta fecha a
porta a porta
eu não sei se vocês viram mas é preciso
que alguma coisa buscar alguma coisa
ruim né
ayew foi embora né calma calma calma ai
meu deus quer aquilo era uma boca da
noite sabe sabe andar com centros falta
agora sim vou conseguir captar a energia
isto mal e não borrar a cueca que o
bicho que houve foi que a esquerda fez a
esquerda é isso mesmo ataque à faixa
roxa eu sabia se eu tomar atenção ou
essas coisas né
a mensagem não me incomoda é agora por
favor
agora preciso ver mensagens é uma coisa
importante a a sério todos mandam
mensagem de preto vai conhecer os nossos
produtos não haja vai conhecer é o venha
conhecer os novos tapetes industriais da
loja venha comer o nosso escuna loja 102
para em uma mensagem por favor não quer
comprar as nossas coisas tá tá aqui a
não aí o cine luz
eu segui lo sem querer a entrou aqui
alguém aí dentro que é o foco que está
tudo preto
aí é o que se chama emendou é muita
pressão é muita opção pra mim é muita
opção pra mim já como é que eu queria
mas não tão aí
ai ai meu corpo calma calma calma calma
da turbulenta sai daqui é uma pedra foi
a porta fica impulso por favor fiquem
puxa isso aí você ganha tem que aguentar
só mais uma faca agora é não há muita
opção muita opção daquelas coisas ao meu
deus acredita na esquerda armário era
mário rápido mario fica impulse impulso
e que ambos fiquem longe por falta
exatamente quem anda à direita direta à
direita da direita é exatamente o que tu
já é isso mas ter o filho mestre do
software fábio neves e fred e quatro de
auxiliá lo em pé que o fim deixando ó
ataque a ai meu deus vou para todo lado
eu tenho tudo foi quem lá vai fechar a
porta e isso fica impulso por favor meu
deus
eu tenho pela porta calma tem pela porta
ai ai a segunda noite vai chegar porque
construir espero que vocês tenham
gostado deste de auxiliá-lo em espécie
sofre disso nove finais
é isso que serve a mais nisto é calúnia
eu não sei se vocês querem por quatro
etapas o nec quiserem mais deixem lá
eles não quiserem mais deixar marcar
mesmo porque o universo gira à volta das
coisas
com isso não interessa mas é isso faz
com que o estado fique amanhã está
próximo